griotte crème sur patte de pavot des
ingrédients qui composent plusieurs
desserts Ukrainiens entre deux recettes
et des champs traditionnels j'ai cuisiné
et mangé en compagnie de nouvelles
arrivantes ukrainienne
Marly snicky Origins
Ukrainiens que je vais déguster ici à
Montréal chez notre hôtesse Tatiana
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il y a des saveurs
des goûts qui vous manquent de l'Ukraine
les desserts de ma mère elle aime
cuisiner mes rêves surtout faire des des
petits gâteaux
tétiana quitté l'Ukraine en 2011 avec
son conjoint et leur fille aujourd'hui
elle reçoit deux amis qui ont fui
l'Ukraine en 2022 pour s'installer elles
aussi à Montréal ensemble elles vont
cuisiner des desserts qui leur
rappellent la maison aujourd'hui on va
préparer un allismeaki alors ce sont les
crêpes rouler avec le fromage cottage et
c'est un plat signature de ma mère pour
les crêpes dans on a besoin ces deux
œufs on va ajouter de la farine
du lait
de sucre
pas beaucoup
15 minutes avant la cuisson dans ce
poêlant d'une grande valeur pour elle
ceci je la portais avec moi ça fait 13
ans de l'Ukraine puis ça c'est vraiment
la meilleure pour faire des crêpes et
quand on est venu
à Montréal on avait juste le droit à
deux valises par personne mais dans ces
valises on avait comme trois cuillères
et trois fourchettes et je pense deux
tasses
on a pris vraiment quelque chose pour
survivre le premier temps et après on
s'achetait des choses
Tatiana gagne sa vie comme conseillère
pédagogique elle-même immigrante
l'intégration des nouveaux arrivants lui
tient à cœur au point le simplifier
personnellement
pendant covid j'ai fondé
et le but vraiment et de faciliter
l'intégration des nouveaux arrivés
depuis la guerre
a commencé en Ukraine on a beaucoup de
projets aussi pour les Ukrainiens
de base pour la garniture à crêpes le
fromage cottage pressé
on mange beaucoup ça puis on le met dans
partout en fait le fromage que tu as
vanille très peu au lieu de sucre
une touche canadienne
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
roulé alors il y a mes amis qui font
juste comme ça qui vont pas fermer les
beaux et on le fait aujourd'hui comme ma
mère a fait elle va aller cacher comme
ça
[Musique]
autre garniture possible la pâte de
pavot et les griottes grillotes rouges
alors c'est comme ça que on peut le
chercher ici à Montréal en Ukraine
chaque personne peut être un arbre avec
les griottes parce qu'on lui mange
beaucoup on fait de la confiture avec on
fait des gâteaux on fait tellement
beaucoup de choses des griottes faisons
de me décrire le goût la différence
entre une cerise qu'on connaît bien ici
la grille sont très sucrés super sucrés
grillades sont un peu sur
je connais cette chanson de mes parents
et ils ont chanté à la maison toujours
chaque jour mais ma mère aussi en fait
elle chante
je pense que c'est très populaire on ne
craint de chaque jour c'est
vrai une fois les Naïs Niki roulaient on
les réchauffe dans la poêle avant des
servir avec la crème ou la crème sur et
du sucre quelle belle table merci
d'avoir cuisiné tout ça on dit
maintenant un Ukrainien ce qui veut dire
bon
appétitiana qu'est-ce qu'elle aime elle
dit ça va être Varane qui avec les
griottes on peut le faire aussi avec
fromage cottage sucré avec des fraises
avec d'autres fruits aussi ouais c'est
ça mais ceci je pense c'est le préféré
des Ukrainiens avec les griottes
et on va pouvoir
le boisson traditionnel
on sent le pruneau oui l'abricot
peut-être aussi c'est très très bon je
me sens très privilégiée d'être avec
vous avec vous trois aujourd'hui merci
comme on dit merci
[Musique]